- I love the pink and red.
This is like a favorite
combination of mine.
- I crafted these.
- You did?
- Yep.
- We died these.
We sewed them into the seam.
I feel pretty proud.
- Fashion is really taking
a play today on the show.
- We do have another shot here?
- Did you have enough of
my fringe? Of my fringe?
Have you met Lucy or Colin?
- I go way back like a
minute now, like 20 seconds.
- Beautiful.
- We're almost at two minutes.
- She's good at head nods.
So I'm just saying you
get an exchange in there.
Well, thank you for doing
"American Song Contest".
Yeah. I loved your song.
- So Fun.
- I'm still singing the story.
- Thank you
- [Kelly] I love also the
song that you're doing today.
It's so bluesy and so
soulful, I'm so into it.
I'm a super fan.
But did y'all get
did you get into
Eurovision, like in the UK?
Did you ever see Eurovision?
- Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
- It's like literally been
around for so long, like 65.
It's crazy.
Well, on ASC, you went back to
your childhood cabin, right?
- Yep.
- And you went with your son?
- Yes.
- So was that cool to do?
Was it cool for him to
see like how you grew up.
- You know, the weird thing is my family
has a reality show called
Alaska the Last Frontier.
And so he watches that
and so he's gotten a
taste of it virtually.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Jewel] But always like
when I get to bring him home
and make him haul the water
and chop the wood it's good
- I was like it's different
from like watching it
and actually having to do it.
- Yeah, totally.
- It's a totally different life.
And even watching that,
just, I keep getting reminded
of your upbringing.
It's crazy cool.
It's like straight up out of
the shows they're making now
like "Yellowstone", almost.
- [Jewel] Exactly.
- Yeah. I feel like it's
like how they're trying
to make films now.
It's like, yeah, I did that.
That's how I grew up.
So you recently opened up
about having panic attacks.
I didn't know that about you.
- Yeah. I moved out at 15
so I started having panic
attacks about that age.
Didn't know what they were.
And then when I was homeless,
they hit a whole new level.
And so I started inventing tools
and techniques to help me with them.
Haven't had them in ages.
And then suddenly when I was filming,
maybe it was "The Masked Singer",
I had my first panic attack in ages.
- Well, probably because you were
in a costume that you couldn't breath in.
- Claustrophobic. I was
a little claustrophobic.
Yeah. So I started posting
because we helped kids
with anxiety disorders.
Those types of things.
And so I started posting more
about it just to help people
understand what they are
and the things you can do to help.
- I had no idea what they
were until I was pregnant.
The first time I was pregnant
and I had one while driving
- Oh God, that's the worst.
- And I was terrified.
It was like, I froze.
And I'd never had one
before, but for some reason
I don't know chemically,
something happened
and I had one, I was
like, this is no good.
Like you freak out.
- Your brain literally goes offline.
So all the blood drains
outta your frontal lobes
and goes right to your amygdala
and your vascular system changes.
Your blood pressure changes.
And so
- What's up Bill Nye?
- Finding things to go.
- Geez. I was like, OK, that's amazing.
- Well, if you find things
that force the, the blood back
into your processing centers,
so smell, taste, touch.
That forces your brain to
deal with the information.
So it forces it to go back online.
- To come back to the scene a little.
- Oh yeah.
- What in the world?
Okay. Have you guys ever suffered
from any kind of panic attack
or any kind of maybe
like on set or something?
Do you ever get like that with?
Like I would get terrified
of what y'all do.
- But I think it's so validating
hearing the kind of scientific side of it
To hear that it is a
chemical reaction happening
and something that needs to be addressed
in that way.
- [Jewel] And it's not rational.
- Yeah. That reasoning part of your brain
literally goes offline.
There's no blood there.
Yeah. It's fascinating.
- And that's the panic.
- [Jewel] Yeah.
Yeah. Have you ever
had anything like that?
- Of course. Yeah, absolutely.
That's just something that just puts you
in your place completely
and you can't move. Yeah.
- Yeah. And it's your
brain noticing patterns.
It only takes two data
points that your brain
even your subconscious recognizes
to some other time that might
have been traumatic for you.
And so it's, I don't always, you know
it took me a long time to figure out like
what were those two things, you know?
- [Kelly] Oh, there's a whole
how the body keeps the score.
So then I could start creating a plan.
- Yeah.
- Cause you go back to that
trauma and you don't realize
you're doing it, but your brain does that.
- But your brain sees the pattern.
Yeah, it's fascinating.
- [Kelly] It's exhausting.
So your new album is
called "Freewheelin' Woman".
So why did you choose that title?
I love it.
- I, you know, I'm just really proud
that I've been able to have my own life.
You know, it's hard for women.
I think it's really hard.
And I've been able to make
a living with my words
with my songs.
- [Kelly] But also have a life.
- And have the autonomy
to move around the world
and my careers, as I saw fit.
And you know, this job
is not kind to women.
It's hard on women.
It's hard on women as we age.
And I'm just proud.
I'm proud of my age.
I think I'm singing
better than I ever sung.
I think I'm writing better
than I ever written.
- My voice is better than when
I was younger, I feel like.
- Yeah. So I Feel like
I just wanted the album
to represent just a sense of empowerment.
- Yeah.
- I love this age.
I love where I'm at
and I don't wanna have to
pretend something else, you know
- [Kelly] It's exhausting.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I'm not into
things that tire me.
You will be singing.
It's called "Long Way 'Round", right?
- [Jewel] Yeah.
- "Long Way 'Round".
Oh my God.
It's so good.
And in this song I wanted to
talk about, because this is
one of the lines and I love it.
"It's sometimes it's the long way round.
You gotta get lost to get found."
I love that.
So what, what about that?
Like why did you write that lyric?
- My life has definitely
been the long way around.
It's been a lot of hard plot
twists that haven't been fun.
That haven't been easy,
but they made me who I am
and I do feel good.
Really I feel so happy
where I'm at in my life.
- I love that for you.
- And so just that encouragement of,
sometimes it is the long way around.
Sometimes it's messy.
Life is so messy but you
come out the other side.
And I wanted that so to be encouraging.
- If there's no messy part though
I don't feel like you
really are truly living.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
You gotta kind of get in
there to figure it out.
- [Jewel] You do, you
got to break a few eggs.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yep.
- [Kelly] Ugh, eggs. So
broken some of those.
(Jewel is laughing)
- Well stick around
because Jewel is performing for us later.
I heard the rehearsal.
You do not want to miss this,
her new album, "Freewheelin'
Woman", is out now.